great book by this guy Joel Wallach and
one a lot of it has to do with nutrition
and it's about mineral deficiencies and
vitamin deficiencies essentially talking
about how people rely on doctors for
advice about health yeah when in reality
doctors are good at very specific things
like if you're a podiatrist you're good
at fixing feet if you're in you know an
orthopedic surgeon you're good at knees
and shoulders and but you probably
don't know a fat nutrition yeah and you
really don't understand like the
mechanisms of ibadas absorptions of
nutrients and minerals and vitamins and
one of the things that I've learned from
doing this podcast is to understand that
the top showing
um it's for a shrink it only has one
mineral magnesium our sports drink has
75 metals and 25 ions amino acids
they're getting their energy from sugar
and caffeine we're getting our energy
from the nutrition which makes your
equipment works better makes your
muscles work better makes your bones
work better makes your liver heart and
everything work better there's nothing
else that even comes close to that as a
sports drink we invented a rebound for
one of our great athletes a professional
athlete Theo Ratliff who's there is four
years old and he lost his 35 million
time there he is unless his 35 million
dollar contract because he had bone
ammonia thrives his knees his hips had a
fracture of shooting arm wrist and so he
made rebound for him we also made the
healthy Bone and Joint pack for him
which is our Healthy Start pack and we
had to come up with a collagen project
or product which was the glucajel added
to the healthy shark pack and it became
a healthy Bone and Joint path guy you're
welcome to listen to more about Dr
wolakore ask him a question I host a
call with Dr Joel Wallach every week 7
P.M Pacific time it doesn't matter where
you are the link is uh in the
description team g'day.com I'm Jamil
bookaboo welcome to joining to the call
listen all participate q a thanks even
like when I the cursory understanding of
it that I have you have to go through
hours and hours and hours of reading and
watching documentaries and listening to
experts and I still have to go back over
and over and over again so I've talked
to doctors before and they've been like
super dismissive about even taking
vitamins and I get angry at them well I
think all you need is a balanced diet
with Dr Joel Wallach who's been
nominated for Nobel Prize for medicine
has a book in the Smithsonian well don't
tell me that there's no benefit to
taking vitamins when Aloha this is Jamil
bookaboo at Team g'day and I'm with Dr
Joel Wallach good evening g'day mate at
teamgaday.com and uh call me and I'll
let you know all about the wonderful Dr
Joel Wallach